well Jeff I think it's safe to say that
we have an amazing crop of all-stars
here how do they break down as far as
your concerns first of all I want to
welcome you back because yeah we loved
having et out here and I love that you
guys brought the whole team because you
really did such a great special last
time so thanks for coming back it's a
pleasure to be back and I have to say
Jeff I love the theme the idea of a
game-changer where did it come from and
how did it become the driving force for
the season well really the real original
idea was I was so excited by the live
audience vote for second chances yeah
that I wanted to do it again and so did
a lot of our team and CBS said no I
think it's a little early let's wait on
that but we already had this great idea
for game changers yeah so we said okay
well let's just do game changers anyway
game changers is an idea that we've had
for a few years and it really was just
waiting until we had the perfect crop of
people and by that I mean some old
school and some newer schools and enough
diversity in the type of game play we
didn't just want physical players like
Malcolm and Ozzy or strategic players
like Sandra we wanted a little more
nuance and I feel like we have
accomplished that we have a really great
cross-section of people who are willing
to make move yeah and that is the
definition as far as you're concerned of
a game changer it's willing to make
moves
not necessarily moves that work but big
moves exactly the thing about survivor
is most moves don't work yeah so what we
were looking for is people willing to
make them right you might strike out
that's okay but you're not just waiting
to be walked you're going to swing the
bat that's the people that are out
that's the people now you've shot and
feed you before you've said many times
that you love it here why was this the
perfect time to come back oh my god this
this location I mean look at it yeah
this is the best location we've ever had
ever
I would I would love to shoot here for
the rest of survivor's history it's that
good the water clarity amazing the
weather the locals it's a direct flight
from LA you can't beat it it's a little
push here than Cambodia I'm not going to
lie yes Cambodia was the other extreme
and
we are very tough yes it was now we have
some incredible all-stars we have of
course winners as well but who excites
you the most on this island wow that's a
great question off the top of my head I
love that Sandra the only two-time
winner was so fast to say yes that she
literally texted she saw a missed call
from our casting director and said I
don't care what it is answer is yes the
fact that she won twice and is willing
to come back awesome
yeah I love Surrey I think the audience
would love to see somebody like Surrey
win actually I also love Sierra Easton
she literally declared her last season
would somebody please make a move any
move that's three ladies you just showed
there ah guys gotta love Tony yeah I
know he's like shot out of a cannon did
you see him prancing around
I loved it Malcolm and Ozzy are both
together because they're they're an
archetype in and of themselves the
jungle boy who can catch fish but hasn't
been able to close the social game I
really like that and I like that we have
a guy like varner yeah going all the way
back to season two he is not physical
now and he's not even really super
strategic he's just amazing with his
words I'm charming they're going I can
convince you to do something that's
terrible
yeah for your opinion so but he doesn't
walk around strategizing he just works
you of course but now we have two
newbies yeah that nobody knows about
right does that give them an advantage
or does it hurt them going it's a good
question because as you said we have not
aired the season that Michaela and Zeke
were on so it's really on them to try to
turn this into look I know I didn't win
I did versus I'm scared of you because I
don't know your game and we did it with
Malcolm and we did it with Russell and
they both get okay with it but I gotta
say if I were playing this game and I
knew what I know about Zeke I'd be
worried he's a very very good strategic
player and if I knew what I knew about
Michaela I would want to keep her around
because she is a close or a challenges
but her social game is what she's
working on right still learning still
learning well this is an opportunity to
learn from
best right so we have also for coal
wrong players that are all fresh in my
mind that's for sure how do you think
they're going to fare I mean we're
talking targets I think one of the
things I love about our show is that
it's not always even and it's not always
perfect and it's there's an imbalance
and there is for that you know you have
four people you can look at that and say
we have to get rid of at least one or
two of them right away but who knows I
mean can any of them win Aubrey seems a
threat I don't think anybody thinks ty
is going to win I don't know anybody
doesn't know about Kaleb and Debbie I
think people still underestimate
marketers like the crazy woman and she
could surprise him so there are so many
questions going into this season and the
burden is on the player to figure out
how to convince everybody else you don't
need to vote me out tonight right I
think everybody believes they have a
target on their back everybody I still
have spoken to does but who do you think
has the biggest glaring massive target I
think the guy asking for it is Tony yeah
she seems to be daring people to vote
him out he's already raising a ruckus
yeah I love the Tony's willing to say
even without speaking much you should be
worried because I'm going to be running
through the jungle looking for idols or
building a spy Shack I love that
enthusiasm and if he can survive a few
tribals and get in he fantastic yes okay
let's talk about some of the twists you
know this game I think has been as
popular and laughing so long because it
keeps evolving we have we have hidden
immunity idols you're adding extra votes
the ability last season to vote out a
jury member was really new and very
exciting anything this season that we
can look forward we are doing one big
change and that is in the case of a tie
vote at Tribal Council there will not be
a revote and so that means we would go
directly to the tiebreaker which is you
can all talk but you have to now make a
unanimous decision and if not those
people that were in trouble are safe and
you're drawing rocks and the reason this
came up is that it started occurring to
me that the way our game is structured
you can actually get a free peek into
the future and see if somebody has an
idol if you have them
players it doesn't cost you anything it
should cost you something yeah so now it
will cost you something potentially a
million dollars and I don't even think
it will result in more tybo's I just
think it will make each vote much more
nerve-wracking because now you're
guessing and you better guess right and
the smart players will realize if I'm in
the minority Alliance and I think I'm in
trouble I could actually take one of my
votes put it on one of my own minority
alliance member night and force a tie
and now force you guys to draw rocks cuz
I just won't agree unless it's one of
your members right you never cease to
amaze me you make it more difficult to
make it more exciting is it just passion
yeah what is the total passion people
think I'm crazy I fell into the perfect
show 17 years ago a study of human
nature and it's just great game that you
can sit around when we're in editing and
just think huh what else would work what
else would make it difficult
what would I hate to see happen or love
to see happen and then ideas just occur
to you and the great thing Aaron about
Survivor is we only need a little tweak
so like the Remo that's enough to send
this season into a bit of a spin yeah
you don't need to reinvent it it's just
maybe just a little tweak any plans to
hide immunity idols in challenges this
season this season we are going to
really mix it up in this sense there
will not be any consistency to where the
idols will be so we're going to change
the game by being completely
inconsistent so the first idols may
require some work at camp to find them
you might very likely find one in a
challenge you might find one at Tribal
Council
we don't know so much of idols does
depend on when they get played because
we only have a certain amount that we
want in the game so if they start
playing a lot of idols then that lists a
lot of them will get you if people don't
play any idols then we may not see any
of these IDs but to your point yes we
have some very fun ideas to keep
evolving where idols are playing in the
game and how you get them yeah and
you've said before you're always open to
ideas for
your teammates right it's there are no
bad ideas here in Survivor because they
can always grow into something that can
change the game and push the game
forward a hundred percent yeah I think
the secret sauce of our success and this
is going to sound corny we have a
psychologically safe environment for
ideas nobody feels threatened to share
the idea that they know is terrible when
it might have a great yes say it and
it's amazing how many a times that
kernel of an idea leads to a full piece
of popcorn and it's you know it's great
you also have hot bodies and little
bathing suits - that doesn't hurt does
it yeah I forgot to be completely honest
it yes we want a mixture of people but I
think the whole notion of this show
being about hot bodies and bikinis it's
not it's why we're still on if it were
just about attractive people those shows
die this is a show that you're at home
watching going she shouldn't do that why
did he say that
yeah why did nobody from one tribe go
try to get the toolkit yes why people at
home are going to go just great they're
watching as he swims he's still swimming
Ozzy's diving down Jeff is saying it
nobody goes he tell Kayla finally says
I'm not even that greatest swimmer but
I'll go to Lake Caleb they don't know
how to work as a team yet right and that
doesn't it sometimes it never work done
anything ever come together is it
straight and you sit at home and you
judge yeah
because you think you've got it figured
out oh I've watched those challenges
before and said I could do that I know
having competed in two challenges that
it is not easy it is not you know it's
funny you say that the the life ring the
opening challenge in which you have to
dive down I went and tested that douve
out went under started trying to untie
knot and came up to the to the water
going up oh my god just a feet I can't
get down and hung up it's so hard and
your Adrenaline's pumping and you feel
the pressure to succeed yes and you are
yelling at them which makes it even your
intent that's the best part
okay I mean it's obviously very early in
the game but who do you think can go all
the way Jeff well who do I think can go
all the way a lot of people
there are a lot of people that can win
this game somewhere some of you may be
your top three okay top three that I
that I'm going to go with winning
ironically are all women Sandra
Surrey and Sierra I don't really know
why I just Sandra could win again which
would be mind blowing yeah sorry I think
everybody wants to win she's a woman
who's coming out so close and she is the
woman who got up off the couch and said
I think I'm gonna try this and she's
become an all-star and then Sierra is
the young mom who came out voted out her
mom forced a rock draw and said please
make a move even if it's me and it was
yeah and she was sent home and she came
back and said I don't care I want to
play again okay you want to know my pick
yes Katie
really I like a style of play I like its
honesty I like his loyalty and I like
there's something in his eye you know
what's interesting about JT is he does
not rest on making great moves at one or
bad moves that got him voted out he has
this pull challenge up against poverty
that he feels like he gave up on yeah if
you chip on a shoulder something to
prove something everybody here has
something to true yeah even you Jeff all
come to prove here right now right now I
know you picked your top three I want
you to pick one player that's going to
go all the way to go against my GT we're
going to have a friendly bet Jerry loser
has to streak the beach you would sure
be yeah maybe I'm not going to lose JT
who'd you pick
Wow just imagine you streaking to be
okay maybe just a beer what no one is
sir
you want to host Survivor you got to put
it on the line alright Sierra okay
Sierra Easton versus JT okay good luck
good luck Phoenix you can't wait to see
you naked that could never make me air
could it may be fun with it we put out
some fun with it
why not right why not funny